o que leva alguém a ser tão altruísta ao
ponto pôr em risco a própria vida o que
provou este homem
o edno eo 30 e 50 anos a saltar para a
linha do metro em nova york para salvar
um estranho de 20 anos
quem aqui da linha mais conhecido um
ataque epilético
o que leva alguém com um longo historial
de dor crônica fazer desafios
desportivos duríssimos por causas
solidárias
será que a psicologia explica isto a
palavra inclusive vem do grego que
significa alma e vir na ciência que
estuda o comportamento humano e ambiente
incluindo processo consciente e
inconsciente
teoricamente os psicólogos dedicam se ao
estudo novamente dos nossos
comportamentos da nossa missão cognição
atenção e também das relações
interpessoais
eu tenho aqui tudo bem
o problema é que durante o século 20
a psicologia de que os quase
exclusivamente à doença mental estava o
que estava errado com os processos
mentais e comportamentais
é verdade que muitos progressos foram
feitos no diagnóstico e tratamento de
diversas patologias como depressão
ansiedade esquizofrenia e outros
comportamentos negativos do ser humano
só coisas negativas as coisas boas de
vidro não interessam
infelizmente no nosso milênio e
inclusive ajudado proibida e com sua
saída em 1998 morte de seu irmão foi
eleito presidente da associação
britânica de psicologia com maior
votação de sempre pela solução criou o
movimento psicologia positiva essa não é
uma doença mental mas possui mental e
visa promover a felicidade e bem estar
agora tive a felicidade de conhecer o
mar quando estava a fazer o doutoramento
em filadélfia aniversário pensilvânia
onde ela era professora
estamos falando da universidade da
islândia foram tempos felizes
eu fui cidades em sua busca em busca de
emoções positivas e prazer já remonta a
tempos antigos tão antigos como a
própria humanidade
filósofos gregos como epicurista fotos e
pensadores orientais com alta de
confúcio já muito se interessavam por
isso em 1943
este senhor quarto disco é abraham
maslow atire positivo não tiver sangue
mas ficou mais conhecido pela sua
pirâmide diz a famosa pirâmide de maslow
por exemplo a hierarquia das
necessidades humanas na base temos as
necessidades fisiológicas essenciais
para a sobrevivência humana e depois
forma ascendente temos as necessidades
de segurança de amor estima e só no topo
temos a coleção pessoal ou seja só
satisfeitas as necessidades inferiores e
que ser humano pode aspirar a ter
utilização pessoal que quando está em
harmonia e pode explorar todo o seu
potencial em 1985
este senhor unger com o nome quase
impronunciável me rally team que sempre
me ralei criou com o site flow que é um
conceito que designa um estado de enorme
concentração em que as pessoas estão tão
focados e desempenhar uma tarefa que
esquecem do tempo e do espaço
é uma felicidade plena mais nada
interessa estão focadas ficam felizes e
ora é precisamente pra apostar e lutar
por esse conceito flu e realização
pessoal que vai adquirir de psicologia
positiva e sua evolução
foto martin seligman que podemos atingir
níveis de felicidade nunca antes
alcançados explorarmos o nosso potencial
os nossos pontos fortes que designa por
cima de outros trâmites podem ser coisas
como o otimismo gratidão rumor até
prometem selma existem três tipos de
vírus foi isso é vida com prazer
with boa de godoy fi e vida com
significado
nem falar isso a vida com o cruzeiro
aprendi mais com os problemas físicos e
com bens materiais
vejo como o hedonismo de epicuro é por
exemplo comer um golo de scott
o bicho tá emfa conduzir um grande
ferrari naquela primeira fatia do bolo
de chocolate em maravilha polícia na
segunda-feira tia também é ótima já não
é a mesma coisa e depois as outras já
começam a enjoar não é tempo de casa o
vendedor bahia
portanto essa felicidade causa óbito são
ea dependência e começa a perder o seu
efeito pela sociedade superficial e
efêmero
do ponto de vista da neurociência x ao
neurotransmissor dopamina que atua em
determinadas áreas do cérebro e
desencadeiam mecanismos de adição ou
seja comportamentos que levam ao vício
godoy fim da vida boa está associada aos
talentos que nós temos
consiste em explorar o nosso potencial
vejo como eu de monize mesmo de
aristóteles é por exemplo ser pianista
durar de campeã e sentir se mais nuvens
ao dar um concerto fantástico e sentimos
felizes e realizados com nossa vida
do ponto de vista da neurociência está
associado a um neurotransmissor
serotonina que se espalha pelo cérebro
criando o estado de alegria e felicidade
é uma sociedade mais duradoura mais
profunda
finalmente temos a vida com significado
que representa algo mais a vida a vida
boa e se usar os nossos talentos mas não
só para a nossa própria felicidade mas
também para promover o bairro o
conhecimento é paz e felicidade dos
outros
vejo como o altruísmo do ponto de vista
da neurociência está associada a
compaixão ea humildade
ora porque só alguns atingem uma vida
com significado o facto a maioria de nós
está na essência o bayern por altruísmo
ou seja os nossos cérebros estão
organizados de forma a sermos altruístas
segundo a tradição budista mexemos com
base em leituras ou seja um bom dado
básica e nata
isto é nós temos para a segunda dose das
opções diferentes com cérebro diferente
que não querem fazer o ganho antes pelo
contrário têm comportamentos psicopatas
antissociais que não sofrem com o
sofrimento alheio
nuno botelho no extremo oposto do
espectro
temos os altruístas sofrem com o
sofrimento dos outros tem um enorme
empatia com eles querem fazer o bahia
querem ajudar
eu empresto 12 bases neurológicas da
meditação e da compaixão descreveu o
doutoramento em 2007
é fantástico perceber o que se passa no
cérebro quando temos este comportamento
quando era pequena
com 16 anos eu apenas tive a felicidade
de viver para marcar os meus pais nessa
altura comecei a praticar a meditação
sai bem como a minha vida mudou desde
então e agora como neurocientista sei
bem com o meu cérebro mudou desde então
isso também significa a instituição de
uma infância e consigo perceber quais os
infantis do my phone no cérebro
está provado que na prática sustentado
mal informadas por mitos alterar a
estrutura e organização do nosso cérebro
aumenta meter e cinzenta em determinadas
zonas rurais e melhorar a conectividade
ganhar entre as diversas áreas
melhora a nossa possibilidade de chamar
a atenção da nossa regulação das emoções
e nossa contínua de nós próprios para
manter o júnior coxinha se nós próprios
que minha consciência dos outros e
daquilo que nos rodeiam possa já somos
mais competitivos e mais bondosos sim
porque o mais famoso está associado a
estes valores antigos tradição budista
como a compaixão ea gratidão a humildade
são essenciais na minha vida
sei bem o que se passa no meu cérebro
quando milito e sei também bem o que se
passa no meu cérebro quando faz fotos
altruístas sei qual é a minha motivação
e o que sinto quando fácil apesar de
como free ter dor crônica mais de dez
anos e não saber o que é viver um dia
sem dor angustiante abraço desafio
esportivo duríssimo por causas
solidárias com o bom humor que o
caracteriza e permite superar muitos
obstáculos
costumo brincar comigo próprio e dizer
que em relação à dor tem uma abordagem
homeopática tratador com mais dor e é
isso que permite continuar a nadar e
correr e fazer desafios inevitáveis
e acredita em desde que comecei a
praticar uma infância de maneira formal
desde que obteve a certificação e
comecei a praticar uma forma mais
científica minha performance desportiva
e esperou
comecei a ganhar as provas todas dentro
nem campeã de natação em águas abertas
isso por exemplo o mês de agosto sábado
domingos sabe mim estava de mim
é verdade eu acho fantástico ganhar
estas provas todos e fico muito feliz ao
princípio a nova face mandava nos nuvem
se pensava honra como é ser compensados
mais fortes tantos anos tantos anos
tantas horas trânsito tanto sofrimento
tentador
ao fim de algum tempo com faço muita
meditação entre a expressão comecei a
pensar mais sobre o assunto e as
vitórias deixaram de chegar outra pessoa
qualquer
e uma prova e ganhar uma medalha ficaria
feliz em cima o que eu costumo dizer aos
meus amigos nada mais lugares chegam
mais para trás e passou a virar as
provas já somos todos campeões
conhecidos foi vai levar já é campeão e
eu fico disse continua ficar feliz não
existia não chegava e pensar eu ganhe
estudo quem mais pode ganhar com isto
tinha que fazer algo maior algo muito
maior do que eu e foi assim que me
tornarei atleta humanitária faz outra
maratona de natação por causas
solidárias em agosto 2017 isto não é a
primeira e única mulher portuguesa
conseguir nadar das bandas até peniche é
mais duro 35 portugal continental
são 16 quilômetros no mar muito bravo
concorrentes fortíssimos e água gelada
mas consegui e ver se vai o orgulho a
chegada
consegui e conseguir com os meus colegas
trouxe um grupo de espanhóis que vieram
propositadamente a portugal fazer essa
travessia ser tão famosa conseguimos
angariar mil euros para jogar os
voluntários de peniche e mil euros para
ser simples
no dia 11 de setembro de 2018
organizei uma travessia solitária
precisa se mobilizar a população para a
doença de alzheimer e promover a
campanha mediana de melancia da
associação alzheimer portugal
conseguimos angariar mais 500 euros a
chuva trouxe duríssima três quilômetros
do lagos e portimão no pior dia de verão
tivemos imensa sorte né
achei os meus amigos estavam
determinados a fazer a travessia e mesmo
nessas condições adversas nada nem
ninguém nos moveu
nem mesmo o fato de esqui porque nós
queremos contratados ter recusado em vez
de tratar
vamos acompanhar um barco de apoio em
greve até o final do ano do barco em
estilo longamente com ela mas eu sabia
determina de cima não colaborar
eles esqueceram de o rival perigoso se
sim o pior dia do verão e que o barco
era novo e não cria danificado
apresentou em meus argumentos dos quais
nem sequer vou falar mas o que mais me
perturbou foi eu ter dito que quem vai
levar
não percebo quem vai no bar que sofre
muito por que deveriam e é muito ampla
ação e um desagradável
eu nem queria acreditar no que estava
ouvindo indignada diz isso não é um
evento de lazer não é um passeio em um
evento solidário e acredito que quem vai
andar sofre muito mais do que tem vai no
barco pois o nosso sofrimento não é nada
a comparar com o sofrimento que tem
alzheimer ou de seus familiares e amigos
e nos momentos mais duros da travessia
que foram muitos foram cinco horas e 12
minutos a nadar
lembrando sempre destas palavras que diz
que me deram mais força e energia do que
todos os réus barras e bananas que
consumir durante o árduo percurso na
véspera
sabendo que não ia meter barco tem
amigos e familiares a tornar me dizer
suzana o favorito não vás estado por
tudo em risco de passar por eto'o vida
em risco
eu já me conhecem se viu que não havia
nada a fazer
eu estava determinado a fazer
francia com as em barco felizmente
conseguimos arranjar um caiaque que nos
acompanhou
mas com as em caiaque eu ter ido a mesma
estava terminada iria fazer a travessia
nada iria mover porque eu tinha
escolhido uma causa e por tudo em risco
para honrar esta causa porque continua a
dar um susto quando faço por causas
solidárias
quando leva nossa bandeira o estrangeiro
estou verdadeiramente naquele estado
falou que gosta de chamar de pio 12 não
fui cidade suprema encostou em tal união
com o mar que deixam perceber onde o
cabo eo mar começa e é neste momento em
que eu sou o mar eo mar sou eu que 13
sendo sublimando numa enorme onda de
compaixão e é precisamente com este
espírito é sempre ajudar quem mais
precisa se fundar a minha própria
instituição para promover a saúde física
e mental pessoas mais saudáveis física e
mentalmente são mais felizes e pessoas
felizes fazem os outros mais difícil e
todos juntos faremos um mundo melhor e
mais feliz
e tu quer ser verdadeiramente feliz
transcendente faz algo altruísta
nunca diga que não é capaz nunca diga
nunca
obrigada
[Aplausos]